♪ ♪
>> Laura: TIME FOR "SEEN AND
UNSEEN" TO EXPOSE THE BIG
CULTURAL STORIES OF THE DAY.
AND THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA WITH
MILLENNIA CONSPIRACY THEORIES
AND LATE-NIGHT COMEDY IS DEAD
MUSICIANS VERSUS POLITICIANS.
IS THAT A SOFTBALL GAME?
FOX CONTRIBUTOR RAYMOND ARROYO
BEST-SELLING AUTHOR, AND RAYMON
RAYMOND, WHY AT THE VIEWS
SPREADING CONSPIRACY THEORIES
ABOUT THE FIRST LADY?
CAN SHE TAKE ANY MORE FROM THESE
PEOPLE?
>> Raymond: IF THIS IS
UNBELIEVABLE THOUGH
PRESIDENT AND FIRST LADY TOURED
ALABAMA WITH THE TORNADOES THAT
TOOK THOUSANDS OF LIVES, STORIES
SPREADING ON THE INTERNET
CLAIMING THIS WAS NOT MILLENNIA
TRUMP ON THE PRESIDENT'S SIDE BT
A BODY DOUBLE.
AND THE LADIES OF THE VIEW
CLEARED IT UP THIS WAY, AT THAT
ONE DOES NOT LOOK LIKE HER,
SORRY.
WE ARE GOING TO GO ALONG WITH
THAT BUT THAT ONE IN THAT
PICTURE.
>> IT'S A DIFFERENT SHAPED
PHASE.
I'M ASHAMED TO SAY, I SPENT AN
HOUR ON SATURDAY INVOLVED IN
THIS.
MELANIA IS A TALL, STATUESQUE
WOMAN AND THE ONE THAT WE SAW,
THE FIRST ONE THAT WE SHOWED,
SHE LOOKS KIND OF SHORT.
>> A RUMOR LIKE THIS COME I
THINK IT CATCHES ON BECAUSE
THERE IS AN ELEMENT OF TRUTH TO
THE IDEA THAT SHE DOESN'T WANT
TO SPEND TIME WITH HIM.
>> Laura: LET ME JUST SAY TO
YOU, JOY, I HAVEN'T BEEN ON THE
VIEW FOR A LONG TIME INVITE ME
ON AND WE WILL DO A LITTLE
COMPARISON OF PHOTOS.
>> Raymond: AN ELEMENT OF
TRUTH.
WHAT IS THE ELEMENT OF TRUTH
EXCEPT YOUR OWN IDEOLOGY WHERE
OBVIOUSLY BY OBVIOUSLY BIAS.
>> Laura: YOU'RE KIDDING.
>> Raymond: THE FIRST LADY
SPOKESMAN CAME OUT AND SAID THIS
IS SHAMELESS PARTICULARLY THEY
ARE TO CONSOLE VICTIMS.
>> Laura: THEY TRASH TALK --
WE WILL GET FOX NATION BECAUSE I
WANT TO TALK ABOUT THAT BUT THE
OTHER THING IS, I CANNOT BELIEVE
THEY PROMOTE THE NEXT SEGMENT
LIKE TOMORROW ON THE FACT THAT
WE REALLY DIDN'T LAND ON THE
MOON.
>> Raymond: [LAUGHTER]
>> Laura: IT WAS FAKE.
>> Raymond: LAURA I HEARD JOY
BEHAR EMPLOYS A BODY DOUBLE.
LOOK AT THAT.
>> Laura: [LAUGHTER]
>> Raymond: I'M SURE,
THAT IS ONLY AN ELEMENT OF THE
TRUTH TO IT.
WE WILL LEAVE IT THERE, DUSTIN
HOFFMAN WILL GET ROYALTY.
SPEAKING OF MEDIA RELATED STORY,
JAY LENO, I'M SORRY, JAY LENO ON
"THE TODAY SHOW" STORY -- SHOW.
AND WHETHER HE MISSED LATE-NIGHT
AND HIS ANSWER WAS TELLING.
I DON'T MISS IT, YOU KNOW,
EVERYTHING NOW, IF THESE PEOPLE
DON'T LIKE YOUR POLITICS,
EVERYONE HAS TO HAVE YOUR
POLITICS.
IT'S ALL SERIOUS.
IT'S ALSO NASTY, AND CIVILITY TO
COME BACK.
JIMMY, COLBERT, EVERYBODY ELSE,
DOES TOUGH AND THAT IS THE ONLY
THING.
>> Raymond: THEY HAVE MADE IT
ABOUT THIS, LAURA ALL ABOUT
POLITICS AND THE AUDIENCES FLING
FROM IT.
THE OVERALL AUDIENCE WAY DOWN
WHEN JAY LENO OR GOD FORBID
JOHNNY CARSON PRESIDING OVER
"THE TONIGHT SHOW."
AND I THINK IT IS BECAUSE NOT
ONLY THAT COMEDY GOT NASTY AND
PETTY AND VERY POLITICAL --
>> Laura: NOT FUNNY.
>> Raymond: THIS IS THE
CARDINAL SIN.
IT IS NOT FUNNY.
IT IS THE VERY THING TEACH US
WHAT WE HAVE IN COMMON AND LAUGH
TOGETHER, RATHER, IT ACCENTUATES
THE THING THAT DIVIDE.
>> Laura: CARSON SAID YEARS
AGO BEFORE HE DIED, NEVER
THOUGHT I SHOULD SPOUT OFF ABOUT
POLITICS.
I'M HERE TO MAKE PEOPLE LAUGH.
I'M HERE TO ENTERTAIN THEM.
SHUT UP AND MAKE US LAUGH.
>> Raymond: MAKE US LAUGH.
>> Laura: JOY BEHAR MAKES THE
POINT ABOUT THIS.
SHE SAID THIS TODAY.
>> I WAS LOSING INTEREST BECAUSE
TOO GOOD.
THERE WAS NOTHING TO MAKE FUN OF
THEY ARE.
>> Raymond: THERE IT IS.
SHE LOVED OBAMA, BUT BUSH AND
TRUMP ARE CORNUCOPIA.
I'M SORRY, THERE IS PLENTY OF
HUMOR TO HAVE ON BOTH SIDES OF
GOOD COMEDIANS.
>> Laura: HOW ABOUT PARENTING,
DATING, ALL SORTS OF THINGS
ABOUT LIFE.
>> Raymond: PLENTY.
>> Laura: AND THE SOCKS IN THE
DRYER.
>> Raymond: THE MOST POPULAR
COMEDIAN OUT THERE, KEVIN,
SEINFELD AND JAY LENO.
THAT BATTLE HAS BEEN IMPROVING
SINCE THE REAGAN MUSICIANS AND
POLITICIANS ABOUT USING SONGS
FOR POLITICAL RALLIES.
THE SONGS THAT BECOME ANTHEMS
FOR A CAMPAIGN LIKE THESE.
♪ ♪
GOD BLESS THE USA.
WORKING 9 TO 5, WHAT A WAY TO
MAKE A LIVING.
MUSIC NOTE ♪ ♪
ELIZABETH WARREN FOR USING DOLLY
PARTON HIT AND SPOKESMAN SAID
HER MANAGER, WE DID NOT APPROVE
THE REQUEST AND WE DO NOT
APPROVE REQUESTS LIKE THIS HAVE
A POLITICAL NATURE.
LAURA, THE LAW ON THIS IS DODGY.
REMEMBER BRUCE SPRINGSTEEN WENT
AFTER RONALD REAGAN.
TOM PETTY WENT AFTER GEORGE BUSH
FOR USING THEIR SOUNDS.
THE LAW IS THE VENUE HAS THE
MUSIC RIGHTS TO BROADCAST,
PERFORMANCE RIGHTS, THEY CAN
PLAY IT IN THE ARENA.
BUT IF IT IS BROADCAST FROM OF
THE MUSICIAN HAS SOME PUBLICITY
RIGHTS BECAUSE THEY SAY THIS
LOOKS LIKE A FALSE ENDORSEMENT.
AND THAT IS WHERE YOU GET INTO
PROBLEMS, BUT MANY QUEEN, REM,
DELL, THE STONES WITH LETTERS TO
DONALD TRUMP.
>> Laura: WHAT A ENFORCEMENT
MECHANISM.
I DON'T GET WHAT YOU WANT BUT
YOU GET WHAT YOU NEED.